Search nick gear for this go.
Yeah,
brick.
Especially if it's hot outside,
which by the way it might get hot here any minute now.
There is a fucking fire in Ventura and the winds are insane right now in the
fire.
V Through Ventura is just tearing things apart.
You've got the alert on my phone in the Uber drive over.
Careful warning.
Warning's bad man.
I mean it was bad and it scares the shit out of me because I love kids
somewhere.
Yes,
there's that for sure.
Um,
but what it scares the shit out of me is that in the short term,
I think most people are going to get out of there if they prepare and move
accordingly.
But you gotta you gotta realize what this is like.
This is something that when you get a fire of this size,
it's burned back that up a little bit.
So you get the numbers just in today,
it's burnt 45,000 acres destroyed at least 150 structures and force 20,000
people,
27,000 people to evacuate and they can't stop it.
They don't have enough manpower.
When,
when something is this big and it's this strong and the winds are this fucking
crazy,
you look at how those trees are blown over,
sideways and these fucking houses are up in flames and it's,
how do they even have enough water?
I have no idea.
I Live City Hall just burned down the city hall building and just them putting
the fire out.
Everyone's water went out.
So there's not enough water.
You couldn't turn on your taps because they used it all to put out city hall,
uh,
wonder if there's like a chart where you could see,
we could go back to nine 11 and post nine 11.
How many women got impregnated by firefighters?
Like how many?
Because remember when firefighters,
like after nine 11,
remember they were real heroes.
Yeah.
No.
People have kind of like taking him for granted until they do something to
actually save your house.
I used to do that bit about they've,
after nine 11 firefighters and cops are getting so much hero pussy,
they were launching it like rotted octopus.
Out of,
out of luck.
What do you call those?
Sling shot.
Sling shot struck it.
I'd have to swat him down with tennis rackets.
I had this whole bit about Europe,
pussy,
they,
it's so true,
right?
Yeah.
Not well.
Then the war came and then all the,
that was,
I think the bit was all the troops are getting the hero pussy that nine 11 first
responders use to get,
and now they're just hanging around bars.
Go and remember me.